so as you're as the number of people who
follow you on Twitter expands
you feel the burden
of the uglier sides of humanity yes but
there's also a similar thing in uh in
the normal world that is if you become
more influential if you have more status
if you have more Fame in the real world
you have uh you get lots of perks but
you also uh have way less freedom in the
way in which you interact with people
especially with strangers because
a certain percentage of people it's a
small single digit percentage is nuts
and dangerous and uh the more of those
are looking at you the more of them
might get ideas but what if the
technology enables you to discover the
majority of people to discover and
connect efficiently and regularly with
the majority of people who are actually
really good I mean one of my
sort of concerns with the platform my
Twitter is
there's a lot of really smart people out
there a lot of smart people that
disagree with me and with others between
each other and I love that if the
technology would bring those to the top
the beautiful disagreements like uh
intelligent squared type of debates
there's a bunch of I mean one of my
favorite things to listen to is
arguments and arguments like high effort
arguments with the respect and love
underneath it but then it gets a little
too heated but that kind of too heated
which I've seen you participate in and I
love that uh with Lee Corona with those
kinds of folks and you go pretty hard
like you get frustrated but it's all
beautiful obviously I can't do this
because uh we know each other yes and uh
lee is has the rare gift of being
willing to be wrong in public Yeah so
basically has thoughts that are as wrong
as the random thoughts of an average
highly intelligent person but he blurts
them out while not being sure if they're
right and he enjoys doing that and once
you understand that this is his game you
don't get offended by him saying
something that you think is so wrong but
he's constantly passively communicating
a respect for the people he's talking
with and for just basic humanity and
truth and all that kind of stuff and
there's a self-deprecating thing there's
a bunch of like social skills you
acquire that allow you to be a great
debater a great argumenter like be wrong
in public and explore ideas together in
public when you disagree and if I would
love for Twitter to elevate those folks
Elevate those kinds of conversations it
already does in some sense but uh also
if it elevates them too much then you
get this phenomenon Clubhouse where you
always get dragged on stage and I found
this very stressful because it was too
intense yeah and I don't like to be
dragged on stage all the time yeah I
think once a week is enough and also
when I met Lee the first time I found
that a lot of people seem to be shocked
by the fact that he was being very
aggressive as their results that he
didn't seem to show a lot of sensibility
in in a way in which he was criticizing
what they were doing and being
dismissive of the work of others and
that was not I think in any way a
shortcoming of him because I noticed
that he was much much more dismissive
with respect to his own work it was his
General stance and I felt that this
General stance is creating a lot of
liability for him because really a lot
of people take offense at him being not
like their Carnegie character who was
always smooth and make sure that
everybody likes them so I really respect
that he is willing to take that risk and
to be wrong in public and to offend
people and he doesn't do this in in any
bad way it's just most people feel or
not all people recognize this and so I
can be much more aggressive with him
then I can be with many other people who
don't play the same game because he
understands the way in the spirit in
which I respond to him I think that's a
fun and it's a beautiful game it's
ultimately a productive one